[Música]
y
en el día 44 de guerra en ucrania el
impacto de un misil en la localidad de
khar grama torch en la pro rusa región
de donges dejó al menos 50 muertos entre
ellos 5 menores y unos 100 heridos el
misil impactó sobre la estación de tren
de la ciudad donde miles de personas
esperaban a ser evacuadas
la presidenta de la comisión europea
ursula von der leyen y el jefe de la
diplomacia de la unión europea y un se
ocurre el estuvieron en lucha allí
visitaron una fuerza común tras lo que
font der leyen aseguró haber visto el
rostro cruel del ejército ruso
posteriormente se reunieron con
volodymyr selenski en kiev y prometieron
más apoyo
y este domingo 10 de abril francia vota
en sus elecciones presidenciales más de
48 millones de franceses se están
llamados a las urnas para elegir entre
12 candidatos durante la primera vuelta
si nadie consigue más del 50% de los
votos habrá un balotaje el próximo 24 de
abril
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo se dan hoy es un
gusto acompañarlos este 8 de abril de
2022 marca un año de cautiverio del
periodista francés olivier hubo ha
secuestrado en mali en nombre de la
libertad de prensa en apoyo a su familia
y a sus personas cercanas le dedicamos
cada mes en esta fecha un pensamiento
hasta su liberación
comenzamos esta emisión en ucrania en
donde se cuentan al menos 50 muertos
entre ellos cinco menores y unos cien
heridos en la localidad de cra motors en
la profusa región de donges que un misil
impactó sobre una estación de tren donde
cientos de personas en su mayoría
mujeres y niños esperaban para huir de
la ciudad ante las amenazas de un
incremento de la ofensiva rusa marina
sardenya tienen los detalles
un infierno en la tierra así describen
los supervivientes el ataque sobre la
estación de tren de clamatos la región
de doñetsk
sinceramente pensé que iba a morir lo
peor es que si esto ocurriera todos los
días en nuestra ciudad sería aterrador
había muchas mujeres y niños
unas 4000 personas en su mayoría mujeres
y niños esperaban ser evacuadas ante las
amenazas de una gran ofensiva de moscú
cuando un misil acabó con sus vidas
fundaciones unidas calificó el ataque de
completamente inaceptable usi a todos
los principales estados del mundo han
condenado ya el ataque de rusia 14
esperamos una respuesta firme y global a
este crimen de guerra al igual que las
masacres de lucha al igual que muchos
otros crímenes de guerra rusos el ataque
con misiles sobre crematorio debe ser
una de las acusaciones en el tribunal lo
que seguramente ocurrirá
en la tribuna guayaquil o podios cobos
inmunes mientras tanto en bolo dianca
continúan las tareas de búsqueda y
rescate entre las ruinas ya se han
recuperado más de 25 cuerpos después de
que las fuerzas rusas golpearan barrios
residenciales
y mis hijos yacían bajo los escombros
acaban de sacar a mis hijos de debajo de
los escombros
durante 36 días la gente permaneció bajo
los escombros y los rusos dispararon
impidieron que sacaran a la gente
en el noroeste del país los residentes
de jarque también limpian los escombros
muchos civiles alegan que fueron
atacados con proyectiles y cohetes rusos
en los últimos días los funcionarios
regionales han instado a los civiles a
abandonar sus hogares
hubo una explosión las ventanas
comenzaron a temblar corrimos al baño y
escuchamos una explosión extremadamente
fuerte
cuando se cumplen 44 días de guerra en
ucrania las fuerzas del kremlin
continúan golpeando con dureza a la
indefensa población civil porque las
autoridades ucranianas califican como
crímenes de lesa humanidad la presidenta
de la comisión europea- ursula von der
leyen y el jefe de la diplomacia europea
y uso cv real se reunieron el viernes en
que con el presidente ucraniano más
temprano en el mismo día visitaron mucha
la ciudad que se convirtió en un símbolo
de las atrocidades de la guerra en
ucrania los representantes del bloque
prometieron más ayuda para armamento y
hacer el ingreso del país a la unión
europea ampliamos en el siguiente
informe
una visita en solidaridad con los
habitantes de mucha una ciudad que
simboliza las atrocidades de la guerra
bajo la mirada de los líderes europeos
úrsula von der leyen anillos de aboga en
decenas de cuerpos de civiles
encontrados en fosas comunes
si lo impensable ha ocurrido aquí
hemos visto la cara cruel del ejército
de putin solo botes morning nuestro
equipo pucha el mundo entero está de
luto con el pueblo de wood hemsworth
que es el que defiende la frontera de
europa la humanidad y la democracia
humana chic quejan de último crossing
la jornada continuó en kiev donde se
reunieron con el presidente voló de
medios de lenski en la agenda figuraba
la quinta serie de sanciones adoptadas
este viernes que incluye un embargo del
carbón ruso a partir de agosto
o supuestos a piatti personalmente
agradezco el quinto paquete de sanciones
pero creo que no es suficiente ellos nos
quitaron mucho nos quitaron territorios
y personas podremos recuperar
territorios y no podremos recuperar
personas y habrá una enorme y justa
responsabilidad por eso estoy seguro de
ello por eso pido ayuda en forma de
sanciones hay que endurecer las de lo
contrario rusia no querrá escuchar nada
ni a nadie mójate soy más al sistema
estamos a sus lados este es el mensaje
que úrsula von der leyen recalcó en
tregua por los límites de la skin
cuestionario que debía rellenar en el
marco del procedimiento de adición a la
unión europea
la presidenta de la comisión espera que
la solicitud de ucrania pueda
presentarse al consejo este mismo verano
entre los últimos anuncios de la unión
europea sobre el conflicto en ucrania
está el apoyo al gobierno de volodymyr
zelinski con más dinero para la compra
de material armamentístico asimismo eeuu
anunció el despliegue de baterías
antimisiles patriot en eslovaquia a
cambio de que este país envía a ucrania
su sistema actual de defensa anti-aérea
mientras que reino unido también
confirmó que entregara más armas para
analizar las consecuencias de estos
anuncios hablamos con alberto hudson
white doctor en relaciones
internacionales profesor universitario y
autor de numerosos libros sobre
geopolítica señor hudson guaita
bienvenido a france 24
ucrania sin ayuda exterior no tiene la
capacidad armamentística de rusia pero
es el envío de armas a ucrania la
solución al conflicto con rusia
mire yo rodrigo yo no creo que el envío
de armas particularmente por parte de la
unión europea vaya a resultar en una
posibilidad para ucrania en esta en esta
guerra rusia diría que no tiene
sustituto para la victoria puesto que
una derrota o en todo caso que rusia no
alcance sus propósitos pueden ser dos o
tres y ello implicaría una catástrofe
verdadera para el régimen de putin y
para la rusia que necesita transformar
su economía en los próximos lustros o
décadas de manera que yo creo que europa
debería comprometerse más con una
continuación de la diplomacia que cesó
el 24 de febrero de pasado y tratar
sobre los temas que precisamente
dificultan la posibilidad de un acuerdo
entre ucrania y rusia esto es la
garantía de una eventual neutralidad de
ucrania la situación relativa con crimea
y la situación relativa con qué tipo de
política
tendrá en la zona del delta ambas si yo
analizó la situación en términos de
grandes potencias diría que la
continuidad extra guerras porque aquí en
términos de las de potencia hablo de
rusia y occidente y cuando habla
occidente más que duro pablo de eeuu en
términos de esta de este anillo mayor
estratégico diría que la continuidad de
la guerra puede fungir como favorable
para eeuu en relación con desangrar a
rusia ahora si yo analizo el otro anillo
local que tiene lugar precisamente en
casi todo el territorio de ucrania yo
creo que aquí europa debe pensar en la
seguridad de europa y en este sentido
debería tener un compromiso mayor con la
diplomacia continuar con la diplomacia
hasta agotar todo lo que se puede
y apostando por la diplomacia usted cree
que sin la resistencia militar de
ucraniana sería posible una salida
equitativa y justa para ucrania en este
conflicto
es difícil la salida es equitativa y
justa porque no me imagino a rusia
renunciando a la península de crimea y
sebastopol y tampoco me imagino a rusia
renunciando a que no se tome algún grado
de autonomía en relación con las en las
zonas filo rusas del tam bass pero sí me
imagino una posibilidad de no guerra no
hablo de paz de no guerra entre ucrania
y rusia si se avanzan en cuestiones como
la garantía de una eventual
neutralización pero europa no está
considerando esto europa está pensando
en llevar a ucrania a su seno político
económico y ucrania va a estar en guerra
porque esta guerra así como ésta va a
seguir en tanto en cuanto el occidente
continúe apoyando ucrania rusia puede
considerar que no están logrando sus
objetivos
e incrementar el nivel de violencia
hasta un patrón parecido y esto ya se ve
bueno en algunas partes de ucrania como
el patrón grozny no ósea una destrucción
un ataque de violencia enorme y un
descenso impresionante de la seguridad
humanitaria como pase de manera que yo
considero que occidente igual en este
caso cuando de occidente de europa
debería considerar trabajar más con la
diplomacia y en este sentido persuadir
sobre todo a selene y pero también a
putin de que hay un camino por la
diplomacia sí y pensando en una ucrania
posconflicto es posible que estas armas
que puede pasar con estas armas después
del conflicto pueden devenir en un
problema en manos de civiles o milicias
no ligadas al ejército ucraniano
bueno por eso utiliza el concepto de no
guerra en el mejor escenario
supongamos que ucrania y rusia logran un
cese de fuego y una apertura de un
diálogo sobre estos tres componentes
relativos con la posibilidad de salir de
la violencia de la guerra bueno cuando
hay una guerra es porque no creo que
realmente vaya a reinar la orden
entendiendo orden por paz por orden en
ucrania puesto que van a continuar
remanentes de un lado de otro y va y
puedan existir algunos incidentes entre
comillas de manera que no veo cerca la
posibilidad de un orden en ucrania pero
repito europa debería tener un mayor
compromiso con la diplomacia
señorita muchas gracias por atendernos
en france 24
ustedes cambiamos de temas porque en
francia 12 candidatos se enfrentarán el
domingo 10 de abril en la primera vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales quién
puede votar son todos elegibles como
candidato electo que pasará en una
hipotética segunda ronda les explicamos
el sistema electoral francés en el
siguiente informe
los votantes franceses eligen
directamente a su presidente por
sufragio universal el voto es abierto
para todos los ciudadanos franceses
mayores de 18 años siempre que no estén
legalmente inhabilitados para votar y
estén inscritos en la lista electoral
las mismas reglas se aplican a los
candidatos quienes también deben mostrar
un sentido de dignidad moral un término
vago sin una definición legal clara y
reunir 500 firmas de apoyo de
representantes electos
cualquiera que cumpla con estos
criterios es elegible para participar en
la primera ronda si nadie gana con una
mayoría absoluta más del 50 por ciento
de los votos los candidatos con mayor
puntuación se enfrentan en una segunda
vuelta aquí es donde entra a jugar el
voto estratégico en la segunda ronda
muchos votantes se elegirán a un
candidato que inicialmente no apoyaron
para bloquear a otro contendiente esto
sucedió por primera vez en 2002 cuando
el ultraderechista jean-marie le pen
llegó inesperadamente a la segunda ronda
su oponente el titular de entonces
jacques chirac obtuvo más del 82% de los
votos el mayor margen en la historia del
país
les recordamos que este domingo 10 de
abril tendremos un especial sobre la
primera vuelta de las presidenciales
francesas como ya les hemos contado más
de 48 millones de franceses están
llamados a las urnas pueden conectarse
con nosotros a partir del mediodía en
hora de bogotá quito y lima
y en estados unidos la próxima jueza de
la corte suprema estadounidense que tang
yi brawn jackson celebró su confirmación
por parte del senado en un acto con el
presidente joe biden y la vicepresidenta
kamala harris en la casa blanca la
jurista se comprometió a que una vez que
asuma el cargo realizará su trabajo con
independencia previamente no reportó al
respecto nuestro corresponsal en
washington cristóbal basket
acompañada de su familia amigos cercanos
congresistas y gabinete del gobierno que
tal y brawn jackson cerebro desde la
casa blanca la confirmación a la corte
suprema de justicia tras un proceso de
42 días de debate en el senado de eeuu
53 senadores al final votaron a favor de
ella y 47 en contra logrando la mayoría
simple para convertirse así en la cuarta
mujer en la máxima institución judicial
de eeuu la primera afroamericana en la
historia y la más joven del grupo de
nueve magistrados que conforman la corte
y empezará entonces sus funciones en
octubre en un emotivo discurso dijo que
ella ha trabajado duro para llegar a
este punto de su carrera y que ha
logrado mucho más de que lo de lo que
sus abuelos imaginaron pero aclaró
varias veces que nadie hace esto por su
propia cuenta que su camino había sido
despejado para que ella pudiera estar a
la altura de esta ocasión finalmente y
entre aplausos y lágrimas de los
asistentes la juez braun jackson dijo
que ella es hoy el sueño y la esperanza
del esclavo
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
con nosotros en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]